lacking that rook on f8 rook f7 on the  board  yeah this looks like you can go queen g5  or rook h5 here  yeah wait what about queen d8  queen d8 oh  he's played it well  that's it game over yeah shaq's just  waiting for the resignation oh no is he  going to mate oh go on go to mate that  would be nice  what do you think about that about how  players allow these mates or don't what  is your opinion on that  i think it's great that players go to  checkmate in in this kind of position  when it crowns the end of a game then  i think it's really nice for for a  player to allow mate  if you're a night down in some hopeless  end game  and you're playing on there's nothing  beautiful about that  yeah to allow this mate fair play to  abby  i think that's really nice you know  it plays yeah exactly